on a deux grands sujets le premier c'est
la violence absolument inadmissible et
dangereuse pour démocratique a été
utilisée hier soir il y a la phrase de
Monsieur CERVA que vous avez vu mais il
y a surtout d'autres éléments de
violence vous n'avez pas vu on avait une
députée et les filles qui a traversé
l'hémicycle pour les menacer un députés
renaissant de lui demander en lisant en
lui disant ferme-la et sortons de
l'hémicycémie
dehors
qui est très grave pour le démocratie
moi je demande des sanctions très
alourdies pour ce type de comportement
qui n'est pas un comportement digne d'un
représentant de la République et qui
surtout montrent que cette hémicycle
n'est pas un plateau de télévision de
mauvaise télévision la violence que vous
avez utilisé hier soir
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
sur l'obstruction je pense qu'elle est
fille c'est pris les pieds dans le tapis
ils ont déposé une niche c'est une
journée ils ont déposé 12 textes la
veille on a enlevé deux et puis ils ont
commencé par le premier sujet qui était
un très joli sujet dans lequel quasiment
unanimement les groupes parlementaires
ont voté pour inscrire dans la
Constitution l'IVG et là on avait
réellement un moment extrêmement fort de
capacité collective de travailler
ensemble sur un sujet et ensuite ils ont
essayé la corrida ils ont vu qu'il
passait pas la corrida ils ont fait
rêver des millions de personnes pour
supprimer la corrida le dernier moment
ils l'ont retiré sans pouvoir débattre
et puis ils ont essayé de passer ce
texte sur les soins donc on a vu une
confusion totale dans la façon d'opérer
de la part de les filles et une violence
qui doit être condamnée parce que ce
n'est pas comme ça qu'on peut débattre
en démocratie alors après sur
l'obstruction quand on met 19000
amendements sur les retraites que l'on
met 3500 amendements sur le projet de
loi de finance il y a un règlement de
l'Assemblée chacun l'utilise comme il
veut oui on a mis des amendements pour
débattre et les filles a fait toutes
séances il n'a pas voulu
aucune notion à donner quand vous mettez
19000 amendements sur les retraites sur
les retraites la question précise elle
est très peu politique les scientifiques
avant tout et un conseil scientifique
qui dit qu'on ne peut pas les réintégrer
en l'état et donc le politique suit en
l'occurrence les conseils scientifiques
on peut pas sur cette question là
pourquoi pas la faire 150 ans de plus
dans ce cas-là quelqu'un va arriver en
disant ben moi je crois que c'est du
tétanos après moi je veux pas
un moment on croit à la science on est
fort on peut choisir les vaccins donc
moi je pense que d'abord sur à côté le
côté politique si la France insoum c'est
vraiment voulu que ce texte passe il
l'aurait programmé en 1 ou en deux il
n'a pas la confusion de programmation
qu'ils ont fait ils l'ont mis en fin de
soirée c'est que justement il voulait
créer le débat et et que ça passe pas en
revanche la question posée elle est
essentielle donc moi je pense que elle
n'est pas politique bien sûr finition
politique mais elle n'est pas politique
au départ elle est avant tout
scientifique et que sur la question des
outre-mer et une question spécifique moi
je pense qu'il faut réunir une
commission transpartisane et que cette
commission dans les trois semaines fasse
des propositions précises sur la façon
dont on traite ces personnel on traite
ces personnels aujourd'hui dans l'état
actuel de la science et des règles on ne
peut pas réintégrer mais faut-il laisser
des gens comme ça sans salaire sans
revenu
il aurait été disputé bien sûr que non
et de
j'étais à Mulhouse au début c'était la
ville qui était touché le plus il y
avait un avec un hôpital militaire etc
tellement le covid était fort à ce
moment-là nous avons grâce à la
vaccination réussie aujourd'hui à ce que
le covid soit maîtrise j'ai encouragé la
vaccination et bien il faut traiter la
question
l'autre grand sujet
cette saisie est très et très importante
et moi je m'en félicite bien évidemment
dans tout pays et vous l'avez dit il
faut de la transparence on a l'origine
de cette affaire si vous avez deux
sénateurs quelques mois avant les
élections présidentielles une sénatrice
PC et un sénateur LR qui font un rapport
sur les cabinets conseils quelques mois
avant il pose les questions que vous
avez posées là si il y a un doute il y a
des questions il faut lever ce doute que
la justice fasse son travail et c'est
après seulement qu'on pourra parler de
scandale etc attendons que chacun fasse
son travail là on phase à la phase de la
justice on va clarifier les choses il y
a des soupçons sinon
vous avez des gens qui ont été
exceptionnés qui n'ont pas été
sanctionnés c'est tous les jours comme
ça là il y a une question qui se pose il
faut lever le doute il faut de la
transparence c'est ce qu'a dit le
président de la République laissons
faire le parquet national financier et
puis ensuite nous pourrons débattre
réellement sur les faits avérés
aujourd'hui il y a des questions qui se
posent le volet doute et moi je suis
pour ça comme vous l'avez dit il faut
dans cette démocratie qu'il y ait aucun
doute aucune suspicion ça y est on va y
répondre